[intro music]
Good morning, Hank, it's
Wednesday, February 7th,
and it's story day.
Our story today is called,
"Everyone Poops in my Pants"
by Hank Green.
My name is Hank,
and I have a small problem:
everyone poops in my pants.
Each morning, I wake up
and dozens of people surround my house,
chanting,
"What do we want to poop in?"
"Hank's pants!"
"When do we want to poop in them?"
"Now!"
[chants] "Hey hey! Ho ho!
Into Hank's pants we gotta go!
Hey hey! Ho ho!
Into Hank's pants we gotta go...
poop."
Now, I know what you are thinking.
You are thinking,
Hank, I believe that many people
have pooped in your pants.
But I remain unconvinced that everyone
has pooped in your pants.
And that is true enough.
For instance, many poor people
haven't pooped in my pants
because they lack the resources
to fly to Montana.
And many babies haven't
pooped in my pants
because they're too busy
pooping in their own.
I'm just saying that, statistically,
an improbably large number of
people have pooped in my pants.
My mom and dad, and my brother, John,
have all pooped in my pants.
Kirsten Dunst
was wearing, and pooping in,
my pants during the entire
filming of Spider Man 2.
The entire Liverpool Football Club
pooped in my umbros immediately after
winning the 2005 UEFA Cup.
German novelist Günter Grass
pooped in my pants while
wearing his Nobel Prize.
Stephen Dedalus
is just one of the many fictional characters
who have non-fictionally pooped
in my non-fictional pants.
Al Roker
had my pants tailored to fit him
and then pooped in them.
Vladimir Ilyich Lenin
died in 1924
but has, nonetheless, pooped in my pants.
George W. Bush
is so incompetent
that he failed to poop
IN my pants,
although he did poop
NEAR my pants
and then later claimed
that he had never intended
to poop in my pants
and that no one in his administration
had EVER talked about pooping
IN ANYONE'S pants.
Having seen his poop,
I can report that it looks exactly
like bullshit.
Wow, those guys must be selling
the President's war plan.
People often ask me, "Hank,
does it bother you that everyone
poops in your pants?"
Yes, it does.
Sometimes something great will happen,
like, the other day Barack Obama came by, and
he pooped in my pants,
and his poop kind of makes me
believe in America again.
But, mostly,
I dislike having people poop in my pants.
But everyone has a cross to bear.
Some people have chronic back pain,
some people are on Team Karen,
some people are Republicans.
Me,
I just happen to have pants into
which people really like to poop.
It could certainly be worse.
It's like Monty Python member
Eric Idle once told me,
while he was pooping in my pants,
[music] Eric Idle [singing] - "Always look on the
bright side of life."
[music continues, accompanied by whistling]
Hank, per the request of several commenters,
I hereby challenge you
to answer every single question in your survey
in one video blog
of 3 minutes and 30 seconds or less.
Yes, you will have to talk at this speed.
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.